I hope you all had a great morning and
that you're ready to get started to
learning a little bit about the future
of c-sharp and what's coming in the next
versions of c-sharp so over the past two
decades c-sharp has evolved into a
really interesting programming language
we've seen the c-sharp team and the
f-sharp and the VB teams taking in
inspiration from other programming
languages like we've seen them take
inspiration from Kotlin and swift and
java and c++ and a whole lot of other
different languages and a few of these
features are making it into c-sharp and
has over the years like generics for
instance came out of the research team
at Microsoft and we had pattern matching
that comes from other interesting
programming languages as well and a lot
of these features are what we're gonna
cover in this session we'll talk about
c-sharp aid and what's coming beyond
that and a little bit around when we can
expect to get this into Visual Studio so
is everyone in here a c-sharp developer
excellent excellent so then I don't have
to teach you the basic of c-sharp that's
good so before we get into what's new in
c-sharp I just want to introduce myself
I'm Phillip Ekberg I'm in Microsoft MVP
it doesn't mean that I'm employed by
Microsoft it just means that I can I go
around to conferences and talk about the
new scene c-sharp and talk about using
Visual Studio and things around the
language and things I like about
Microsoft so I'm kind of working for
free as a marketing person joking aside
you can follow me on Twitter just ping
me if you have any questions during
after probably couldn't do it before the
talk but you can ping me on Twitter if
you have any questions and I've got a
free book on c-sharp as well that you
can grab if you just check out my
Twitter and if you ever come to Sweden
I'll take it for our dive as well
because I love diving
alright so in c-sharp we have all these
amazing features over the years we've
had in productions of things like you
know generics we have a sick cannot wait
things that make the language a lot
easier for us to work with it also makes
it easier for us to write code that
breaks so we need to be very cautious
about the features that we introduce in
our programming language and especially
how we use them you know in the early
days of c-sharp c-sharp came out almost
two decades
I think it's 18 years old now a lot
happens in 18 years the first version of
c-sharp had what you needed and the
reason they released his sharp is to
compete with Java so we got only the
normal things it runs in a run time you
got the finals and then switch and stuff
but then you want more things in the
language to make it easier for you to
write better applications so they
produce things like generics which is
kind of a groundbreaking feature in the
language changes the way that we write
applications right the same goes for
async Anna wait it changed this the way
that we work with resources no matter if
it's web resources or a database call or
reading files from the disk
if this was a feature released in
c-sharp 5 we still see improvements in
the coming versions of c-sharp and i'll
show you a few of the features that
they're adding in c-sharp probably 10
but we'll get into those features later
on but what they're making changes in
async/await means that we need to just
learn a little bit more about how this
affects our applications and how to you
know get accustomed to these features to
write better applications we all have
favorite features in the language and
stories around things that change the
way that we write the applications I
have an interesting thing happening to
me when c-sharp 3 came out they
introduced the implicitly typed local
variable also known as the VAR keyword I
remember having a conversation with a
co-worker he tried to convince me that
when you use the VAR keyword you're not
running dynamic code so I had to
decompile the application just to prove
him wrong or just to educate ourselves
because I wasn't really understanding
all of these features either so one of
the really good ways to learn these new
features is to introduce them in the
language D compile the application then
look at the il and see how it effects
your application that's how I've learned
a lot around how c-sharp works
internally and of course dynamic came
later on in c-sharp 4 and then he later
on in c-sharp 6 and so forth we got even
more things at a two language but I
won't bother you going into all the
features released in c-sharp one through
seven point three an interesting fact
though is that with seven and seven
point one two and three they did
something that they haven't done before
so in the first fifteen or sixteen years
of the c-sharp language they never done
a point release of the language
so think about that for a second how
come that they can now do point releases
which means that they can just with a
small update of visual studio that can
increase the or incrementally change the
compiler this is due to the fact that of
this project the Rosslyn project
rustling is an effort inside Microsoft
to rewrite the c-sharp and VB compilers
it's also known as the darknet compiler
platform this has been around for a
while as well so I imagine a few of you
already know about this but what you
might not know is that they were working
on this as an open source project and
they have for a few years as well this
doesn't mean that they work with this as
an open source project like Apple does
they're open source Apple does internal
development and then release the source
somewhere and you could just download
that Microsoft work as a true open
source project with the rustling project
which means that they take contributions
from the community they have discussions
on github about language Steve about
language features so this here is a page
for language features status it's things
that they want to introduce in the
language for instance we have something
called default interface methods at the
bottom here now we're getting to that a
little bit later on but we have a ton of
more features here that they talk about
I want to add into the language so what
happens is that they might not have
people internally that have capacity to
build these things or they might not
just have the time right now so the
community can help out to build these
features as well and that's a great
addition as well so this means that we
can help evolve c-sharp as a programming
language and you'll notice here that
it's my avatar up here so I've made this
huge contribution to the darknet
compiler platform my in fact went in
here and picked a spelling mistake so
that's my great contribution to this
project all joking aside though ever
anyone can go in here and help out not
only with spelling mistakes but help out
with things like introducing features
into the language a few of the features
that I'm going to show you here today is
things that have been introduced by the
community or the community have been
very involved in making sure that this
adapts to what a c-sharp developer
expects we also have another page which
is another repository called the c-sharp
language repository this is kind of the
specification of things they want to get
into the language so Rhossili is the
compiler part of things this is the
language I guess the specification of
what's going into the language some
time so they have all of these champions
or epics or whatever you want to call
them they have things here like how do
we make nullable work better in the
language so they have a champion for
null reference types which I'll also
show you later on and they have all of
these different things that they want to
add to the language and people can go on
and discuss these different features and
they can even say that I want to improve
this I want to build this and I wanna
help out contribute to this so if you
have a really sharp eyes or maybe
binoculars on because I made the fonts
that's really small here but at the top
here it says that this is c-sharp a
candidate is due to be released
somewhere around 2080
I don't imagine how we're doing in
c-sharp by then so whoever set this is
end date yeah I don't know what they
were thinking but anyways it's probably
just a placeholder right so they'll
update that and I'll talk a little bit
more soon about when this is coming into
Visual Studio but it's based on all the
things that we have listed here it's
about seven percent complete right so
based on that if we know that C sharp
eight is gonna be released soon
some of the features might not make it
into the language even though we're
talking about them but just because
they're not making to this version of
c-sharp doesn't make mean that they're
not getting into c-sharp 8.1 or 8.2 or
nine or ten or X or whatever even want
to call the next version so when is he
sharp eight gonna be released well I had
hopes for this to be released with
Visual Studio 2019 which is due to be
released on April 2nd they have this
launch event that anyone can participate
in online and they're gonna release
official CP 2019 now I just read an
announcement I think they released
yesterday where they said well we're not
going to release c-sharp eight with
Visual Studio not 2019 we're gonna wait
until we feel comfortable with both
c-sharp eight and dotnet four three and
then packages in Visual Studio 2019 when
it's available when it's ready for for
you to work with but that doesn't mean
that you can't use the features we chose
to be 2019
that's totally confusing so they will
actually ship c-sharp eight as well as
dead core 3.0 with Visual Studio 2019
but you have to enable the preview of
the compiler as well as the SDK that
you're working with
so you'll get gradual updates with
visual studio where they update the
compilers but as long as you don't
enable any preview features the next
version of facial studio will still be C
sharp 7.3 so C sharp aid and dotnet core
3.0 is going to be released some
sometime this year and a few of the
features that we're going to get into
the language is some of these she's our
bait features and I'll go through a few
of these features in Visual Studio now I
did something really stupid I updated
Visual Studio a few days ago and
everything broke so a few of the
features we'll just have to imagine that
they work most of them still work but
you know so this here is Visual Studio
2019 it's the release candidate version
official City 2019 but before we can get
into exactly the features that are
getting into c-sharp 8 I just want to
quickly run through two features added
in c-sharp 7 just in case someone
doesn't know them it gets really hard
following along because a lot of the
bigger improvements in c-sharp 8 is due
to things like tuples and pattern
matching we could probably spend an hour
talking about just couple of pattern
matching but that's not the point
so in c-sharp 7 they introduced this
thing called tuples now temples have
been around for for a long time but in
kind of a different way now it's a
first-class citizen in the language
which means that in this case here I can
say well this method call here returns
two things I could even say that it
returns a lot of things but I don't know
why you want to do that you could just
introduce a class gets more readable
right but you could do this if you want
you this creates a couple with multiple
different fields and what's interesting
with these tuples I'm not going to do
that because it breaks everything else
is that I can create this couple here of
values that will be mapped into the
tupple that's returned so 100 will be
mapped into X and 200 will be mapped
into Y kind of kind of obvious right and
then when we call this method I can save
our point is equal to get point
sidenote the reason I update the visual
studio was because when I started coding
some of the demos visual studio would
deadlock so I just had to update just to
make sure that I could still live code
right so when I call four points here
sequel to get point what would you
expect that I get out of this thing here
well if we say point dot we in fact get
it way for us to use x and y so this
here is a really nice addition
previously when using tuples you would
get item 1 item 2 and so forth so that's
a really nice addition but this brings
us into something that they call
deconstruction now this is another way
just to do the same thing instead of for
doing VAR point here you can do int
exiting fly inside this tuple syntax
here and that would just map the values
but what would you imagine happens if I
change these around actually this is the
wrong way around so what would you
imagine happening now so I'm returning
X&Y from my get point I'm expecting Y an
X down here at the bottom it's actually
not mapping this by naming its mapping
it by position it's called positioning
matching position matching so Y here
will in fact get the x value so this
here just shows that it can be a little
bit fragile so don't do this it would
probably be better off just saying more
here that will make more sense so this
brings us into deconstruction
deconstruction is a way for us to take
the topple and create some other tuple
that looks similar but in this case here
I say well I have this tuple here of x1
and y1 in fact this crates two local
fields instead of putting this in a new
type of variable so I can simply use x1
and y1 here but it's still tuples syntax
and then we can make this in different
ways we can say that will we have this
simplified version of saying well I have
a variable or have two variables x2 and
y2 and just map those values correctly
so that's tuples it's super simple
really but still we need to understand
tuples and just how how they work and
that they are existing in the language
now another thing added to UC sharp 7 is
pattern matching as anyone done any
other programming done C sharp like
Coughlin's or swift no one perfect
um why don't you so that's perfect
because that means that pattern matching
might be be new to you now pattern
matching is a way for us to say well I
have this class or I have this thing and
I want to apply patterns to understand
which thing it is but I don't want to be
too explicit about that and of course
we've been able to do this in the past
if I want to have this shape here and I
want to check well is this shape a
triangle is it a rectangle and then I
want to cast this to something else we
could of course do shape get type and
then type off so forth right so this
here becomes really verbose and then you
need to be typecasting if you want to
use that particular rectangle and so
forth you get the idea right so how do
we do this better
well we introduce pattern matching in
this case we use this switch syntax to
say based on the shape data that I have
here in the case of it being a triangle
capture this as a local variable of T
and then I can use T inside this context
so that's neat
what I can also do something that they
introduced earlier in c-sharp is a way
for us to do you know exception filters
where we can say if this exception is a
HTTP exception and the status code is
400 or something like that there's a
syntax for doing this it's the one
keyword we can apply that here as well
so I can say in case of this being a
triangle capture T and when when T and
we have two sides we have a it's not
equal to T to be then run this context
here and then I can have another case
down here which is where triangle we're
trying triangle captured as T wanted
something else right so you could have
multiple different cases here using
pattern matching this is really nice
because this means that I don't have I
don't have to do any typecasting I can
use this syntax to just ensure that this
is a little bit better but we've been
able to do this for quite some time now
this has been available since c-sharp 7
which is a while so how it has this
improved in c-sharp 8 the reason that we
talk about this is because the next
things get really confusing if you don't
know anything about pattern matching so
in c-sharp a they introduce something
they call recursive patterns now
recursive patterns is let's think of it
as a way of us to apply multiple
different patterns
we can match on certain different things
so in our case we said when this is a
triangle I can match to a few different
conditions right now I want to say that
we're a link case of I want different
patterns to say well if the it has these
kinds of attributes or these kinds of
traits or these property values then I
want to get into the context so just to
show you an example of this I'm creating
a shape here just a triangle
super simple then I call a method call
explain shape which is going to use a
few different things first of all it's
introducing a new way of us to do
pattern matching it's introducing
something called switch expressions so
you'll notice here that I have this
weird syntax or this weird expression
where I'm saying well I want to return
something which in this case it's going
to be a string I'm gonna return a string
based off what the shape is and then
each case inside this switch is in fact
going to be a um and then this
expression here right so this is like an
expression body member pretty much so on
the left hand side we have a pattern
this is the same that we saw earlier so
I can say we're need to triangle then do
this only when a is not equal to B and
when that's the case we return this
string super simple then we have other
ways of us to apply patterns which is a
new way for doing this in C sharp 8 we
have something called positional
patterns so how does that work
in this case here I'm saying when
there's a rectangle and it's when these
things have these different values but
what are those things so this here is in
fact a tuple but what does that what
does that mean in this case here well if
we're going to the rectangle we've
introduced something called a
deconstruct a deconstruct is a way for
us to get a representation of the object
so I'm saying here that the first thing
that you get out of the deconstruct
which is simply just a way for us to get
a topple out of this the first one is
with its height then it's a point so now
if we go back and look at our switch
expression in fact what's happening here
it's saying when the width is 0 for the
rectangle and when the height is 0 and I
don't care about the point then run this
thing here that make sense that's pretty
cool
so we can use this in different ways as
well and I get I'll get into on
permutation of this where it makes a lot
more sense in just a little bit but
let's stick to the the shapes and the
rectangles now so this here uses or
leverages to deconstruct the
deconstruction so it could change these
two different things here and I could
even capture the point like this and
then I can use that point here as well
alright so you can do all kinds of crazy
things and then we have something called
a property pattern so in case I don't
have the deconstruct in case this here
the one at the top here is a little bit
too verbose for me saying what I'm
looking for values that I want to use
when for all of them so I can use this
property pattern instead where I say
we're just match these two rectangles
where the width is 100 and then this
returns this string here as well so this
is multiple different ways for us to
match on different types of patterns of
objects and their different traits and
then of course we can have multiple
patterns in here and they're all matched
in order so the one at the top will be
matched first so we have this example
here where I just match any any
rectangle if I were to move this above
this one here hopefully this this
doesn't break Visual Studio whoo that
was close every time I see that little
thing come up say I'm working on
something I'm just whoa this is gonna be
crazy so this here it's gonna say that
well this case will never be you reached
because you're catching all the
rectangles right so that's a few nice
additions and then of course how do you
do a default for this what if there's
other types of shapes in my application
well you can say you have a default
pattern where this underscore just as
with with this thing here at the top or
I say I don't care the underscore I
don't care
pretty much it's short for I don't care
then we do the same thing here at the
bottom for anything else just catch all
of these different things so this is
pretty cool so this here means that we
can do all kinds of crazy things now
imagine if you have expression body
members which is a way for us to
introduce
a syntax like this here right so I could
do this instead now I can say I have
this explained shape thing now I don't
need to have the curly braces and the
other things right how would you do this
previously when you have the if it's
type off and then you cast it in and you
check the different values that syntax
gets really nasty but in this case here
when you use a switch expression you can
use this with with expression body
members in all honesty we're just saving
these characters plus the the curly
brace at the bottom but someone who I
said that it's all about saving
characters because we don't have too
many characters of writing our entire
life so we just make the C sharp team
write them for us all right so we have
some other ways to do this as well this
here if we run this it'll of course work
in this case here it's gonna say that
these different sides are not equal it's
gonna say it's not equal to B because we
passed this triangle or the sides are
different and then we can run these
against the other patterns as well
another example of this is a topple
pattern now imagine the case where this
example actually comes from the c-sharp
blog where they talk about these
features and i think it's a really good
explanation of how to do tuple patterns
so imagine we call this method called
open the door or open door we send the
current state of the door which in this
case is locked we want to open the door
and the final parameter here indicates
that we have a valid key to open the
door kind of makes sense right so there
are multiple different ways for us to
build this state machine or this logic
in our applications but with expressions
and would switch expressions this here
gets pretty nice especially with the
topple patterns so in this case here I
create this topple with values so we
switch based off on these three
different values so this is look at this
as a topple right and then we have more
tuples in here which need to match those
particular values so we can say when the
state is open then you want to close and
you don't have a key well you can close
the door you don't have me the key for
that and then of course are different
cases for what you don't have
kena tried to lock it or you tried to
open the door it's locked you don't have
the key and so forth so you can build
all of these really amazing things using
the pattern matching and switch
expressions and then of course if you
try the close to door when it's not
closed or when you tried to close the
door and it's already is closed you'll
throw an exception so you don't have to
return everything from these different
things so this expression here allows
you to return which state the door will
be in once you perform your operation
doing this with traditional approaches
it's a lot more chatty there's a lot
more code to it now of course you
shouldn't take this to the extreme
extent I've seen people kind of
replacing all the original statements
with this so imagine this case where we
have I want to take a boolean and get
the visibility out of that so let's say
that we work in WPF we rinse Ameren I
want to change the visibility of an
element based off a between so in this
case here we simply say well we're gonna
switch based on the current state which
is the boolean and then for true it's
gonna return visible and if we fall it's
gonna return hidden even if it's null
because we all know that you have three
states on a boolean it's gonna blink so
don't do that it's like it's this is a
really bad approach to do it don't
replace all your if and else blocks with
switches and pattern matching because it
doesn't really make any sense now
finally there's one more interesting
approach to this so a more real-world
scenario as well as apposed like as
opposed to the explain shape example you
might have this idea of well I want you
to grab something from the web so we
have this example where I show you the
code here we get a shape from a web
response so let's say that we call on
API this is need to be converted into
something it's going to give us a HTTP
response meditation this method is going
to be asynchronous now of course we can
use the switch expression for this as
well so we could say here that this Sena
synchron's method it returns a shape
when it's done when the only
asynchronous operation is done we use
this switch or the switch expression
syntax to say when the message is has
the status code of these different
values then run these different things
so when it's a 200 okay we can extract
shape from the message if it's not
modified we might have a cache where we
load this thing from and then if it's a
bad request forbidden or other types of
exceptions for other types of aesthetics
codes we just throw different exceptions
of course you can solve this with a
normal switch in case syntax as well but
then you get more like every case you
need to have a break or a return and so
forth this is just a little bit less
chatty in your application makes it a
little bit more nice to read and
probably a little bit more hard to work
with all right so that's recursive
patterns next up is a feature called
ranges now this is the thing that broke
when I update a visual studio so what's
interesting though is that I can code
everything in the show studio and I can
run it from command line so I'll do that
two things that we have in here it's
features introduced in earlier versions
of c-sharp where this span of T it's a
way for us to reference a chunk of
memory and then work on this chunk of
memory without copying this array or
copying the sequence of data so imagine
that I have this huge array of numbers
or strings and I want to say I want to
get the middle ones you don't have to
copy the middle ones into a new array
you can just simply point to the start
and finish element and you get a new
array out of that or new reference to
that part particular part of memory so
they did a lot of this in I believe
unites p.net core and just improve
performance a lot so ranges is a way for
us to express how we want to grab this
piece of data so you see the squiggle is
here telling me that you don't have the
things you need a visual studio to run
this but I know I do but there's some
mismatch between visual studio and the
at the runtime or the compiler so what
I'm saying here is that I want you to
start off from the fifth element and
then give me everything one from the end
so start off with number five index five
which is number six and they gave me
everything until one from the end so
this should give us six through nine and
then of course this gives us a reference
to that particular part of memory and we
can run a for each on that because it's
a lineman role so if we run this it
should the first section here in this
example should say six seven
eight nine which you can see here it at
the top hopefully then next up we have
another example of this where we don't
do a slice we simply say I want you to
use the normal array syntax and pass
this this range in as a not as an index
you can do multiple different things
here now so you can say I want to get
either an index an index is a reference
to a particular item as well using this
kind of syntax then you can pass an
index which is normal if there's an
integer and then you can pass the range
that gives you a new span of the type
that you're working with so this here
will of course give us one through four
but it's a little bit more compact than
the first example then of course we can
use this in index syntax as well to say
just give me the index this will give us
the index to the fifth element from the
end and then it can be really confusing
to specify two index s if I can just
expand this here you can say that I want
to get I want to start off from four
from the end and go to two from the end
I don't know what you might want to do
this but this just shows a way for you
to express that so you have to index s
and then you can use that together with
this range syntax like you have two
different variables and you start with
the range syntax and if we run this it
should give us you can see that seven
and eight so it's starting off at four
from the end and then gave us two
elements from that we could of course
also say just give us some more elements
or give us everything until the end
right so we could do different ways
suffice to expressing this using ranges
and this is something that's been a way
around for a long time if you work with
Python or other types of programming
languages so those two are pretty much
coming into c-sharp eight because
they're in this release candidate as
previews now next up is one of the
probably the most sawed off feature and
the language is null reference types so
the idea behind null reference types is
that when they started off building
c-sharp they made one huge mistake and
that was introducing nulls in the
language it's really hard to remove
nulls now
so a way for us to solve this problem is
to make it easier for us to know when
there's potential no reference
exceptions or no reference problems so
imagine that we simply now say in my I
could change something in my
configuration of this project and say I
want to enable noble context what this
does is that it then interprets
everything as unknowable it's not gonna
break the application it'll simply give
you warnings when you look at in you can
get hints that well you should probably
do something about this so in this case
here I'm saying well string in this case
can be null and that's totally fine my
my application handles the cases where
the name is not initialized but what if
I say that this here shouldn't be no
well then we get some squiggle is here
on the constructor to tell us that you
should probably initialize name because
you require that in your application
this here is just a hint for for the
time being but imagine being able to
turn this into compiler warnings or into
accept or into breaking things in your
compiler right it breaks the build that
would be great because this here is
gonna tell us that well you have a
potential problem and of course if you
were really good you would then change
name as well so you cannot change it
externally if you introduce a
constructor parameter for it you would
make it immune Amol and so forth but
that kind of requires a huge effort in
most applications it's easier for us to
simply just remove it and see where it
kind of breaks because what this does
now is that it doesn't give us any
problems inside our person class but
where does cost interesting implications
is if we look at where we use this so
imagine that we use this in this
mythical insert or update we can say I
have this person here am i trying to
access name here but it's going to tell
us that well there's a possibility that
you're gonna get a null reference
exception so it's Kurt it's gonna start
telling us inside our applications or
inside our code here that your potential
issues you should probably solve that I
have two ways that I can solve this
right off the bat here if I know that
this is not going to be a problem or if
I'm if I'm worried that this is gonna be
a problem I can simply say well don't
get the length if this is no or I can
say that I promise that this thing here
is not going to be null and just go
ahead and give me the length anyways
if you do this you're gonna get into
trouble not by me you're gonna get into
trouble by the compiler the same goes
for the parameter the parameter that we
have here we can say here that this
would potentially be no which then tells
us that well you should probably do
something about that because person here
shouldn't beam also in case this person
it's no we don't get the name and then
we don't get the length but then you can
also say well I really want to get the
name and this here starts to get pretty
nasty I don't particularly like all the
banks in the code but you can do this if
you really want to you now an
interesting take on this is what happens
if we say that this here is not knowable
and we pass and we pass actually we do
this we'll pass null into the to the
method that's probably not a good idea
right so passing Nolan here now is a
potential problem but I know that I can
promise that no it's not gonna be no the
problem goes away that's awesome I don't
know if this is gonna make it into the
final version but we'll see
all right so and then we have something
else in here which is interesting we
have this new coalescing assignment so
instead of me having to say person is
equal to person and if it's not all the
you've initialized that I can say if
person is not I'll just create a new
person for it I like the syntax but it
can get pretty confusing because what
happens if you kind of remove that you
can have a problem it's hard to it's
easier to make a this a problem rather
than the old syntax this is just easier
to misunderstanding anyway so that I
think this is a great addition to the
language and John skeet has a great blog
post on how he did this in no time where
he just introduced these Noah built Noah
nullable types mobile reference types
and just found a lot of potential issues
I think someone made a calculation of
how much money has been lost due to null
reference exceptions and that's a lot
question
so your question is if that maybe
pattern came out of this so that if if
it's null he do something in the mood to
not know Li do something else yeah for
sure
so you have multiple different ways to
solve this right so you have you can
either you just handle it like you
normally do that you create a new object
if it's no but we want to get into a
place where we don't have any nulls at
all in the language pretty much but
that's gonna take a law a lot of effort
and a lot of time the next feature is
using electricians this is simply a way
for us to not have to write color braces
again it's about saving characters so
look at this example here I don't have
using around my HTTP client I'm simply
saying create this HTTP client as soon
as this context that it's Houston is
completed go ahead and dispose of that
so this means that when we reach the
this here it'll dispose that it's a nice
addition again saving characters and
just making the code a little bit more
readable because it doesn't make sense
to I guess it it makes a lot more sense
because a lot of cases you want to do
this alright then we have another
preview feature now when I install the
the release candidate this feature took
a little while to get get going because
you had to change the compiler to look
at the preview features in c-sharp eight
so we have C sharp eight and then you
have C sharp a preview features they're
apparently different so in this case
here I'm creating this application
inside my application I call something
called compute here which then runs some
over-engineered method to compute
something I like to over engineer my
solutions now I really don't but in this
case I like to do it because what I'm
trying to do here is I'm just
concatenate the the integers or I'm just
adding these together to get the length
of something or a value out of something
but the problem with local functions is
that they can capture the context they
can change things in your class
so if we remove this static from here
which is what's introduced in c-sharp
eight we have this local function that's
now capturing the context outside of it
it captures
the class the instance and the captures
everything that it has access to in the
method so we can go ahead and change the
name which is a property in our class
and we can go ahead and change this
value where we used to value inside the
method now in order for us to speed up
the performance a little bit we can
introduce the static keyword this
introduces a way for us to not only
increase the performance but also it
promises that there's no side effects
the local functions have their use case
some cases you can just break them out
into external functions but in a lot of
cases it might be nice to just have them
in this this nested context this world
it's a nice thing if you tend to use set
local functions the final feature that I
can show you in Visual Studio there's a
ton more features that we're going to
talk about but I have to use PowerPoint
slides for that unfortunately because
they don't have they haven't made them
into the language yet and honestly I
didn't have time to build it myself
because I don't know how to cover a lot
more I just know what to show all these
cool things again joking aside in this
example here we have something called a
synchronous stream so a lot of the times
you might want to work with data that's
streaming to your application imagine
that you're reading a file from disk
you're reading something from memory
you're talking to a website you get
bytes and chunks at a time right it
downloads the data as it goes so would
it be very nice for us to be able to say
a weight for each item that we're
getting out of this enumerable now we
can of course say a weight in front of
get here but what that does is waiting
for the entire thing to complete well
this new syntax where we put their
weight keyword in front of the for each
says is that each item is going to be
brought to you asynchronously so if we
have a look inside
actually let's run it first and just see
what the output is like hopefully this
feature works this is going to stream
out the numbers to the consoles as we
get them into the application ill you
say console.writeline to print out the
data into the console so get here allows
us to do a few different things
first of all we marked this as a sink
like would do with any type of
asynchronous methods then we use
something new call on a ie a sink
enumerable which is going to return a
string one for each item so each item is
going to be an integer and then I simply
have a for each for loop that for each
item is going to return a value
but each value is only brought to you
after 300 milliseconds because we were
just delaying for its vanna milliseconds
here and then this thing here returns to
value a less confusing piece of code
would be to look at how do we do this
for if we're loading something from the
disk so I have something here that loads
some lyrics from a file so again I'm
using this using declaration here just
to make sure that I can use my entire
stream inside my method here and then
side note again this thing here I don't
think this particularly looks nice and
in addition to c-sharp sometime in the
future is to be able to do this in one
line like this so you can get rid of
that that's also a nice addition anyway
doesn't work now so what this is doing
here is that it's loading each line
asynchronously
let me just pull it up and then it's
going to return the line and then just
to simulate that this is going to be
loaded from the web or something or that
I have a really slow mechanical disk
it'll delay for 400 milliseconds so this
means that it's going to load a line
from my file and for each line that
we're going to get it'll do something
with that line it'll return that to you
whoever calls this method as long as
they're using this weight for each
syntax so if we run this the the syntax
for this is very similar so again we
were saying a weight for each item or
for each line that we're getting out of
lyrics get lyrics so now if we run this
you can get this song
rickrolled all right so this just shows
you that you can now use these as secret
streams to get data in an asynchronous
manner so you don't have to wait for an
entire chunk of code to be completed and
prior to this feature being added to the
language I've had situations where I've
tried to write the syntax without
knowing that this is coming in c-sharp
aid but it just doesn't work like when
you do this you try to return something
from an asynchronous context and it just
doesn't work because it does there's no
support for it in the language but now
we see char right there it is supported
so I think this is pretty pretty great
features and this is what we can try now
in this show Studio 2019 except for the
ranges but I might that might just be
something local on my machine alright so
let's go back into PowerPoint and I have
a huge chunk of features or a lot of
features that are potentially getting
into c-sharp 8 or c-sharp 10 or who
knows which version of language they're
going to get into one of the things
they're looking at and you'll see I have
links at the bottom of each slide to the
particular language features of the
discussions on github and I'll share
these slides later on on my Twitter so
you can go ahead and check these out if
you want you now one of the things I
want to add is this thing called target
type view exception so again saving
characters we no longer have to write
var triangle is equal to new triangle
instead we say triangle is equal to new
so we saved 3 characters that's great
although in situations where we have
this dictionary here we have a
dictionary where the keys of string and
then we have a list of integers as the
values we can simply say new here and
that'll just create that entire thing so
the amount of characters that we say it
or the amount of code that we don't have
to write is starting to expand right and
then the same goes for this internal
thing here we can say that just create a
new thing for what the dictionary
expects and I do believe they had to
modify the wrong time to make this work
because there's no support for doing
this I'm not entirely sure but again
this is actually a feature that one of
the community members helped out
building into the language and then
here's a small feature if we work in
deconstruction what we had to do earlier
was in order for to create the default
values for these two things in this
deconstruction would have to do this but
why not just be able to say that gave us
a default of this and the compilers
figured it out
just making the code a little bit more
readable and more maintainable I guess
now how many of you have tried to do
have done your own custom attributes and
wanted them to be generic one two three
a few if you do asp.net I've had many
situations where I wanted to do this so
in c-sharp a introducing generic
attributes so previously you had to do
your custom attribute and pass the type
into the constructor and the code just
got a little bit nasty we don't want to
do that's this anymore
but instead what we want to say is give
us just a custom attribute often you or
you can just introduce this generic
constraint or your type I think this is
a good addition this is probably
something that's going to be very useful
next up is something called color
attribute caller expression attribute
imagine we have this this function lives
inside the debug class so we have debug
data search which takes a condition
which is if you say my name is equal to
Phillip or array it's not equal to null
or array dot length is equal to 1 or so
forth you have a condition that you need
to assert on now the second parameter is
the message that you want to pass that's
gonna tell you if this assertion did
fail or or not what this caller argument
expression is doing is kind of pointing
to the same thing here right so it's
pointing to the condition so that means
that we no longer have to specify this
manually what's gonna happen here is
this thing here is going to be compiled
down to something looking like this so
it'll just take the entire expression
and put that inside a string so this
this attribute here just figured this
out for you this is a great addition
especially if you do logging or we're
building a logging framework right so
don't have to pass this message to
yourself and somehow it just figures
this out
now imagine if you worked in programming
languages like go there's this really
interesting feature that allows you to
pass any type into a method that expects
something that looks like the type it
doesn't have to implement the interface
doesn't have to be the exact same class
you just need to share the same traits
as that particular type so what they're
doing with usings is that they were
doing a pattern based approach to this
so in this case here our class has a
dispose method which means that I don't
have to implement I disposable to to be
able to use this inside my using block
now in programming languages like we're
just like go they take this one step
further and I hope that they're gonna do
this in c-sharp as well so imagine the
case where you can pass anything into a
method that expects an interface an
interface should just tell you which
type of methods you should have on your
class it should be a requirement that
you class implement the interface as
long as it has the same methods and the
same signatures I think it would be a
great addition to the language to just
allow you to pass anything into a method
that expects the interface right not
everyone probably agrees with that but I
think will be a good addition to the
language now one feature that I don't
think that I particularly like I'm not
convinced that this is a great addition
to the language its default interface
methods so this means that we can now
introduce methods that have a body on
our interfaces or an implementation on
our interfaces so our interfaces is now
taking a different turn and allowing us
to provide logic inside the interfaces I
don't think that makes a lot of sense so
in this case here we have this is an
occasion interface in version one the
the person that built this thing just
introduced a normal synchronous version
of authenticating the user and we
implement this in our application and
everything is well and then someone
decides to well I want to update the
interface now what happens is I pull
this into my project and I get compiler
errors because it no longer compiles
because you're not implementing the
members but what I'm doing here is I'm
providing a default implementation for
this now this here is of course very
very this here is good this here works
and will allow us to just compile the
application and run the code
so imagine that we have the same
application we update our nougat package
we'll get this new thing we don't
influence anything in our application we
can then still call authenticate async
and it'll give us an old user so this
here is a valid case for it but I can
put whatever I want in here like I can
put a lot of really nasty logic in here
this here starts to turning to multiple
inheritance because if you have multiple
different interfaces having multiple
different implementations of things you
can just pull in the implementations
from a lot of different places now
compared to you multiple inheritance you
don't have the the instance or this
diamond problem that you would in C++
but it's still a wave like it's still
not the best thing ever I guess I'm a
particularly sold on this but I know
that a lot of people that provide
packages and you get and provide
libraries out there really love this
feature because they get a lot of hate
back when they break applications so
you're saying you still do get the
diamond problem now that's interesting
okay
so this is like multiple inheritance it
is alright so I definitely don't like
this feature then again it's probably
the people that provide you with this
packages if you do the libraries and
stuff they like this because they don't
get a lot of hate back when they break
your applications because they can just
add things instead of just requiring you
to implement all their new things then
again they could just introduce a new
interface I don't know what the problem
is with that all right so that's an
interesting feature being added to the
language we'll see if it gets into
c-sharp eight or nine or ten or
whichever feature get the language or it
gets into now we talked about the
neutralizing assignment I like the one
at the top here this is a normal
traditional syntax that we do you can
also be a bit more expressive to say if
X is not equal to null does introduce in
Teresa why we're going to X but now you
can say X question mark question mark is
equal to Y I guess it's sometimes it's a
little bit better to save up on
characters but this is a little bit more
explains it a little bit more especially
if you come
developers that worked in different
languages but I need to see sharp this
thing here might be very confusing and
that's also something that you struggle
with when getting people into your teams
right we're also getting things like I
talked about the switch expressions
relaxed ordering off referent partial
modifiers alternative interpolate
converting strings stack allocation as
the context these are just features that
I don't know not worth showing off
they're just very edge case features but
not a lot of us believes so with that
being said that's C sharp 8 right so
what's happening after C sharp 8 what
can we expect coming in the next version
after the one that we have now well to
be honest we can't really expect that
we're getting any of these features in
c-sharp by it either because when
they're gonna drop c-sharp a they might
pull back features and they've done that
in the past so we just have to be very
glad if we do get a lot of features in
the language hopefully they're gonna
skip 9 and just call it C sharp X
because I think that would be a much
better naming for the language you
probably shows you that I've done more
marketing than programming for the past
years sorry ok so what's gonna come in
the next version of c-sharp and again
don't be sad if they cut the features
and they don't make the cutting through
language I've been bitten by this a few
times before I'm really excited about a
language feature getting into for
instance C sharp 6 record types and this
just didn't make it into the language
and IV pumped and you know getting
people really excited about the features
and then they just don't make it into
the language so one of the features that
they're looking at and these are all
suggestions from get up so I took all
the the champions and the different
things they're talking about adding it
to the language we can do this today we
can see we can have this negated
condition if statement where we say well
if shape is not a triangle or shape if
not shape you say triangle this here
doesn't really read very well so what
about what changes up and say if shape
is not a triangle that's nice
or if not shape is a triangle I don't
like that or introduce give you key word
and say on let's shape is a triangle I
don't like that either I'm not trying to
convince you which one is best but this
one is
because we already have the keywords but
would have it's not in the language
right increasing one more keyword for
just one purpose doesn't make a lot of
sense in this case anyways and then
we're might get some updates to the way
that we can work with null so we get
this way of if it's null we just return
and then if it's not we can await the
task for no conditional Waits
how about we simply have syntax for
saying well if bang tasks or sorry a
wait bang tasks this here would then
just await this if it's not know this is
an old suggestion so this here is
probably gonna change to I don't know
question mark double bang underscore who
knows something else the bang here says
it promises that it shouldn't be no in
other cases so this here should say
await this I promise task is not gonna
be null so maybe should be question
working and then of course we have
record types record types has been one
of those things I mentioned I hope to
get this into c-sharp six when they
started writing the c-sharp compilers
this is what's one of the features they
talked about introducing especially
since it made a lot easier to use
features with a Roslin project so record
types is a way for us to kind of make
this a little bit better as well as
making the code that we write a little
bit shorter so in this case here I can
convert my triangle of shape with all
these different properties in the
constructor into this thing here that I
call a record that's really good
so what benefits do we get out of this
well it introduces a whole lot of things
under the hood imagine the case I have
this simple one-liner that says that
says what I had here at the other slide
and then it just introduces the
constructor it makes everything
immutable because you can't change a
mean C will get true equality checks
where you can check the values against
each other it doesn't have to check just
a reference will get things like the
width method which allows us to work
with this in a true immutable manner so
you can say I want to get a new version
of my triangle as a totally new object
but with a little bit changed value and
of course then we get the deconstructs
you can use it with pattern matching now
the reason that this hasn't made it to
the language is because it's really hard
to implement getting this implemented it
E is easy but making it work for
inheritance is really hard
if you have to mutable objects then you
inherit from one of them it's gonna be
costly interesting side effects so I
would suggest just don't allow
inheritance from record types but they
just want to make it perfect for all the
different cases so this might make it
into a future version of c-sharp
hopefully and then declaration
expressions I mentioned this I would
like to change the way that we can
initialize that character or the line of
text that we saw in the the demo that we
had so just move this into the context
instead just make the code flow a little
bit better and of course why not make an
update to dictionaries as well this here
is a way for us to do a collection
initialize our own dictionaries but what
about we can make this look more like
Python that would be great yeah it looks
really good right so if you like these
things you should go on to get up and
just plus one and hopefully someone's
gonna build them I don't think everyone
is loving this feature but I think it's
a great addition just makes the code
more readable and in a little bit more
nice alright so a few more features that
I don't have code for type classes is
one of the features that we might be
getting into the language the reason I
didn't I don't have a slide for it is
because I'm not smart enough to explain
it simple as that and then we don'twe
struck members parents of span of T now
I don't understand
so span of T say sequence of an array
right it's a sequence of bytes so how
would params of span of T work I don't
know how that would it would just be a
longer a right right and then we might
get an that is equal and or or II sequel
assignment operators just like the no
equalizing assignment where you say
question mark question mark equals this
this here would somehow figure out a
condition and just set your variable
based on something I don't know how that
would work but they were looking into
adding these things as well so with all
that being said like in c-sharp one
through seven points we've got all these
really interesting features and
especially past c-sharp six we've seen a
huge amount of features being added due
to the fact that they introduced a lot
of the Rossum project you know we have
improvements the async in it wait then
we even have the a so you can await
capabilities which are now also make it
into languages like JavaScript so
not only is the c-sharp team looking at
other languages like Auckland and Swift
and Java and JavaScript but they're also
helping other programming languages
becoming better by introducing things
that are working really well in c-sharp
so your question is the proposals that
I've talked about are they endorsed by
the c-sharp language team so that's a
very good question and what happens is
that you can put up one of these
suggestions or an issue on the Rosslyn
project and what happens is it goes
through language design meetings and
they talk about them internally as well
so if a lot of people from the community
really wants a language feature they're
gonna vote on it and then it goes
through a process of where they
internally talk about how would this
work in the compiler and then it
translates into one of these champions I
think that's the word process that they
were using so it is people internally on
Microsoft that work together with the
community and the c-sharp specification
team to make sure that we don't
introduce things that shouldn't be in
the language yeah they're all champions
so you're asking if all the things that
I've talked about these champions yes
they're all in the champions list there
might be one or two that have been from
other places as well or on the Ralston
repository where they're also talking
about features but there's nothing in
here that's that's from a community
member that's not on the rosslyn or
c-sharp language repository where it's
been talked about internally so we got
all of these features prior to c-sharp
aidan with c-sharp aid we get pretty
much even more features we get kind of
the same amount of really amazing
additions to the language and I think
it's a really interesting time to see
that c-sharp takes shape from other
languages and takes shape of how we
build applications now versus how we
build applications 20 years ago it's a
huge different how a huge difference how
we work with with the web how we work
with databases and all of that and the
language evolves into that with a
sinking a weight and with things like
record types which is really good for
when you're generating code and so forth
so I think my favorite feature is being
added now to see her babies the pattern
matching improvements in the way that
you do switch expressions having worked
a lot with Conklin recently I found that
it just makes the application a lot more
readable the code is a lot easier to
work with if you don't make it hard on
yourself and do things like I did with
the boolean right so you're asking if he
feels more like functional programming I
haven't done much of functional
programming so I couldn't say but maybe
someone from from an F sharp experience
no yes so you're saying that it seems
like c-sharp is taking the approach of
being more functional and that's a very
good point and over the years that's
been the case as well
they've taken things from imperative
functional and declarative programming
languages
that's why language integrated query
made it into c-sharp as well so they
took sequel into c-sharp right and now
they're taking F sharp stuff into the
language as well just making it work for
anyone and although I like writing the
switch expressions and more functional
approaches you can still use the
traditional approaches and don't use
that so well a problem with this it's
that we'll have a lot of different
permutations of the same type of
application the code will look very much
different than what it could do in the
past all right so that's all of the
features in c-sharp 1 through 8 pretty
much so it's been a real pleasure being
here if you have any questions after the
talk just ping me on Twitter come up
here and talk to me I'll be around the
conference and hopefully I'll see you
next year as well and don't forget on
your to vote on your way out
ah got a question so you're saying that
some of the features that require you to
get things into dotnet the framework or
dotnet core will make it into core but
not the full framework so yes that's
that I think it's true I couldn't swear
on it but things like ranges will
probably be across the framework as well
as as dotnet core it really depends on
if it's a runtime change or if it's a
change as in how you use things in the
framework so if the runtime change they
need to make like this new thing that I
talked about if they need to do a change
in the runtime that's that's probably
only gonna happen in darknet core but I
couldn't promise you on that so you have
to to look out for that alright thank
you so much for coming
don't forget to vote on your way out
[Applause]